are you excited for injustice to story
mode well we got another look at that
story in a new trailer and it involves
one heck of a cranky gorilla I'm Matt
and this gamespot news update refuses to
make a Harambee joke the new trailer
focuses entirely on a new society of
super villains called the society look
they're evil not creative anyway this
group of baddies is made up of
characters like scarecrow Captain Cold
and Catwoman and they're led by Gorilla
Grodd the angry ape threatens both
Superman's regime and the Justice League
but it's not entirely clear where each
group will stand in the story the
trailer could be teasing Batman and
Superman joining forces but I'm not
totally sure about that also how does
Brainiac fit into this story you may
have a lot of questions so make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to be the first to
know all the answers injustice two
launches on May sixteenth for ps4 and
Xbox one the fighting games roster
currently sits at 27 characters but on
the injustice to website there are 11
spaces yet to be filled preorder bonus
dark side isn't part of the visible
characters on the site so that brings us
down to 10 we're not sure of we know
there will be nine dlc characters thanks
to the game season pass so it seems like
there's still one launch character left
to be announced we'll keep you updated
as more is revealed but if you want to
get in on the super hero fighting action
check out the official breakdowns of
Captain Cold and bane
[Music]
you